fighting game Community has been rocked
by allegations of financial
mismanagement the allegations were made
by tournament and crowdfunding platform
matrino against Arturo NYC Furby Sanchez
a street fighter player and tournament
organizer now a matrino source has
confirmed to me that they plan to
further address the allegations in the
coming weeks so let's dive in and take a
calm look at the Hard facts
laughs foreign
guys before we get into the video we
like to take the time and care to make
sure we get these stories right and we
love covering the fgc so if you enjoy
the video feel free to drop a like and
hit us up in the comments and if you're
not already subscribed and you want to
support our work that's a great way to
do it cheers okay so really really quick
let's explain what matrino is they're a
company that was founded in 2015 that
are an easy way for tournament
organizers to handle tournament brackets
crowd funding and payouts all in one web
page essentially on December 30th 2022
matrino issued the following statement
about Arturo Sanchez it said that he had
quote broken their terms of service by
mishandling prize pool funds so for the
uninitiated who is Arturo Sanchez also
known as NYC Furby or TS Sabin Arturo is
a member of the NYC fgc a professional
Street Fighter 5 player sponsored by
Beast coast and a prodigious tournament
organizer he is also the single biggest
fund razor on Match Arena through his
contributions to match Arena has
generated 478
442.80 towards this poverty-stricken
community where you have all of these
people competing putting their lives on
I say lives on the line because you
sacrifice you cannot get your time back
art is probably today best known for two
things organizing fighting game events
and trying to optimize them on PC I'm
not trying to minimize Art's abilities
as a player because he's qualified for
Capcom Cup this year and quite frankly
his dalsum is just insane
oh God
but his playing doesn't have anything to
do with the accusations not really
because what he's being accused of by
matrino is breaking their terms of
service to fully disclose things I've
had great interactions with both matrino
and Arturo I've done quests on the
matrino site to help contribute to prize
pools and uh I've watched plenty of
events put on by Arturo even subbed to
his twitch channel from time to time so
now that we know the players involved
after the match Reno tweet art replied
that things looked bad but that it was a
misunderstanding he agreed that the
payments from the last couple months had
been late due to personal issues but
said that he had paid masterino back the
full amount that was due to players and
that they would soon confirm that a few
days later art took to his stream to try
and communicate his side and after about
an hour he was joined in that stream by
Rob TV but there were some
inconsistencies in the account for
example where is that money that was
being discussed was it in his Paypal
account or or was it in the match Reno
account you know like what's the
difference between if that money's in
your bank account what's the difference
between that and me and taking that
money and buying sneakers with it you
know what I'm saying and either way if I
take that money and it's sitting in my
house
you mean if it's not where it's supposed
to be you mean if it's still sitting in
the matrino account like uh you're still
sitting in the master you know account
not paid yeah
okay but I thought you said but I
thought when you paid it out to NYC
Furby right PayPal he seemed a bit
shaken throughout honestly and the
stream probably didn't do much to clear
things up it was later delisted but he
did touch on a bunch of things I'll
return to in a moment but before we move
on let's be clear on one thing if art
did fail to pay out on time then that is
a breach of the matrino TOs there were a
lot of people there are a lot of people
that I didn't pay out on time yeah so so
I'm almost one of them so like I do
apologize I do apologize for that once
again so on this count at least art
admits that he picked up he should have
paid people on time he didn't and that
is a breach of the TOs so matrino was
within their rights to ban him and they
have it really does suck that it seems
like personal issues involving his dad's
Health were involved here but at the
same time people might be relying on
that money and it's important that it
gets paid out in a timely manner for a
lot of reasons a lot while people are
back blowing me out to do like a lot of
things like I was actually like in the
ER like for like weeks for like weeks
like I wasn't looking at nobody's phone
man and I wasn't making and like I
wasn't making any of the known like the
public like until until this stuff came
out I did not make any of this public
like do you think I want to say on
Twitter that oh like you know I'm in the
ER my family's near death no I would
never want to say that man it sucks to
even have to talk about it on stream and
at this point it seems like no one's
disputing these facts now if art did pay
back the outstanding amount and if
matrino did say that they would confirm
that publicly I can understand why he
thought that this thing would be over
pretty soon unfortunately we never got
that confirmation from matrino and if
you ask me it's probably because as soon
as these initial claims came out they
probably received more accounts from
other people whether those accounts are
real just errors or intentionally
malicious it's hard to say but they bear
looking into no matter what because
match Reno is kind of dealing with their
half of the situation in the meantime
other claims started to crop up about
art so let's put aside the issue of late
payment for now because he admits that
he paid late it is a breach of the
matrino TOs and there's really not much
else to say about that okay let's look
at the second thing that people were
saying about art some notice that in the
past art had paid out the prize pool of
tournaments that he had run to himself
now this isn't necessarily something
that's that surprising because you can
find other tournament organizers doing
the same thing on Match arena in Art's
case he said that sometimes a player
didn't have a match Reno or the player
didn't speak English and the site is an
English site you know there's a lot of
things that could prevent somebody from
logging into the matrino site in those
cases he would pay them out manually to
their PayPal or sometimes even use cash
so like so like I'll go over some
specific time so number one
when the player did not when when one of
the players did not have like a match
trainer ID or I could not contact them
like those are the time those are the
times where I paid myself and I paid
them off-site right that's number one
right
there were also like events where I was
dealing with uh international players
that did not have a match Reno account
did not know how to navigate the site
those are the time those are the times
where I paid myself and uh I've paid
them and I pretty much do have receipts
for it now according to Art this was a
thing that he sometimes had to do and
match Reno understood that now based on
Public Information it's hard to say for
sure if matrino definitely knew that
Arturo was doing this but I could say
that other TOS have done it as well and
he says that they knew that it was
sometimes necessary and it was okay so
paying yourself out a prize pool to a
tournament does look kind of suspicious
but bear with me for a moment if Arturo
was just scooping entire prize pools
since he started doing events on Match
Reno where are all the people whose
money is missing and like I said earlier
I think probably this accusation has
caused a lot of people to triple check
their receipts and see if maybe there
was a payment that they were supposed to
receive that they didn't and that's
totally fine in a lot of those cases
there might be something that was just
missed there could be errors or who
knows there could be things that were
literally withheld but I haven't seen
much evidence of that so that leads us
to the third claim and that is that
Arturo was skimming a percentage from
the prize pools first off let's go to
Art's words on this people under this
impression people under this impression
that um I take
you know I was under salary for my match
Reno and taking Cuts guys the reality is
is this
from from from
October of last year until until late
this year until like until until maybe
like the last month that's like the last
month or two before I got let go I was
actually an unpaid employee at matrino
that is right I was working for them for
free Not only was I working for them for
free I was actually still donating the
pots
and yeah yeah for my October of last
year so basically every tournament that
I was doing on the matrino platform I
was taking a loss to actually feed the
players Bart says he was working for
free basically but his co-workers at
matarino knew that he would be taking a
cut from prize pools to cover expenses I
made public on these vods and you can
actually go through my entire YouTube
channel there have been many times
multiple times actually where I've said
on stream and I've made it aware to the
players that that yes like I did take a
cut to pay for to pay for expenses so
there's been times where like I've said
like 10 15 and it's actually documented
on record on vods so now we need to talk
about cuts on Match Reno and this is
something that's built into the core
website functionality it is absolutely
possible for a tournament organizer to
take a cut of the funds as demonstrated
in this tutorial video by matrino CEO
and co-founder Grant Farwell by default
match Reno makes it so there's first
place 60 second in place 40 percent
now let's go ahead and add another
payout I'll make this one a little
different let's let's add a password
let's make that catastrophe not a
percentage let's just make it twenty
dollars so you can see a breakdown like
this on some pages for example this
Jazzy circuit event not affiliated with
Arturo shows that the to is taking half
the prize pool and in this case you can
see that the event description just
calls out the fact that the streamer
will receive a cut what I'm trying to
say is that match Reno literally does
allow tournament organizers to take a
cut either a flat feet or a percentage
from the prize pool and if you set up
the event yourself you can see that it's
possible to hide these fees but in the
case of the events that Arturo ran on
the matrino website the page typically
didn't show this in that previous clip
Arturo talked about how he mentioned the
cut as well on stream during these
events I didn't have time to scrub
through literally thousands of odds
because that's how many events that art
has helped the fgc put on so I couldn't
necessarily confirm that he also pointed
to a DM with Elvin Shadow who's the CEO
of Frosty frostings which seems to imply
that at least this tournament organizer
was aware that art was taking a cut the
DM says that quote the match Reno page
end quote said 15 and I showed you that
event earlier so art has admitted to the
late payment thing he said that he
messed up and that he was sorry for that
but I think that this prize pool cut
thing is really the issue that people
will focus on going forward I haven't
been able to get any receipts about
whether matarino knew or didn't know
about Arturo taking this cut which he
also said he only took after he was
taken off salary if Arturo was under the
impression that matrino knew hopefully
he has some receipts for that and will
present them soon the Elven Shadow DM is
a good start but he doesn't work for
match Reno it may prove that some
tournament organizers were aware of the
cut and honestly I'm sure some were but
did match Reno know we don't know yet so
where does this go from here well Force
at matrino was able to confirm to me
that the company is planning a live
stream to further address the situation
in the coming weeks although they
weren't able to say exactly when it
would be and Mr fanatic a former Marvel
3 player and a twitch streamer did his
own stream defending Arturo this week
that included some receipts while many
others have reserved judgment until we
get some more information art was banned
from some East Coast tournaments and
removed from Team spooky but his sponsor
hasn't dropped him yet and some of the
biggest names in the scene don't seem to
want to talk about it okay one last word
on this situation for me Arturo made a
lot of the fgc happen and you can't just
take that away from him but we also need
trust and that starts with transparency
if art took cuts and the right people
didn't know that stealing and I'm not
going to defend that even if I also
accept that he should be getting paid
something for the work that he's putting
into these events of course he should on
the flip side I'm not going to pretend
that Arturo was always trash and
terrible for the fgc and I'm definitely
not going to hassle the man for trying
to unwind with the game that he loves
while this whole thing is still ongoing
at this point it kind of feels like
we're waiting for matrino to say what
they believe they're still owed by
Arturo and what they want him to do
about it in the meantime this thing will
drag on until we get the eventual live
stream that I mentioned or perhaps until
we get some more receipts from Arturo
side but frankly I can't see how the
current situation helps anyone
[Music]
foreign